[Música]
salud en directo américa de france 24 +
romario zalaya en el estudio mar hoy
vamos a hablar de la salud y la
tecnología porque tras la derogación
ante el derecho al aborto en el tribunal
supremo de eeuu muchas mujeres llamaron
entonces a borrar las aplicaciones del
ciclo del ciclo menstrual porque este
llamado buenos dias raúl así es y se
hicieron virales muchísimos tweets de
información a través de redes sociales
que pedían a las mujeres ya personas que
pueden menstruar que borrarán sus
aplicaciones que rastrean el ciclo
menstrual estamos hablando de
aplicaciones que además de las fechas
también pueden rastrear pues actividad
sexual intentos de quedarse embarazada
también pues métodos anticonceptivos que
se usa una información que en un país
donde el aborto y el derecho al aborto
peligra donde no hay un acceso seguro
puede servir para criminalizar a las
mujeres entonces antes incluso de
empezar a hablar de las aplicaciones
concretas que pueden servir para eso
hemos revisado también la literatura
tanto social como científica que existe
alrededor de esto y vemos que es que no
sólo son las aplicaciones las que dejan
una huella digital rastreable con temas
de nuestra salud en este caso también
con temas pues el aborto no se ha usado
ya no sería nuevo a partir de ahora sino
que ya se ha usado en eeuu por ejemplo
mensajes directos a través de servicios
de mensajería como whatsapp o sms o
telegram para demostrar que una mujer
estaba buscando tener acceso al aborto o
que aborto también se han usado por
ejemplo en las búsquedas por internet
por ejemplo sobre métodos del aborto o
lugares donde pueden ir incluso la
geolocalización que transmite nuestro
teléfono puede ser usada en estos casos
porque pues si se sabe en qué lugares
hay una clínica de aborto se puede saber
cuánto tiempo ha pasado una mujer una
persona ahí pues también todo eso son
pruebas que no son nuevas decimos sino
que ya se han usado en procesos
judiciales en el que se acusaba a
mujeres de haberse sometido a un aborto
en un momentos en lugares en los que
estaba prohibido a esto ahora se suma
pues toda esta preocupación con las
aplicaciones particularmente que además
tienen muchísima más información estas
pues se han comprometido a mantener la
privacidad pero la preocupación ya ya
crece ya existe ahora la pregunta mar
realmente las aplicaciones si pueden
suponer un peligro en este y otros casos
depende un poquito también de las
políticas que tengan de privacidad esas
aplicaciones y eso es lo que vamos a
revisar ahora también con cifras pero
raúl ya te digo de entrada que no son
cifras muy alentadoras si estamos
preocupados por nuestra privacidad son
cifras de la universidad mcguire de
australia del centro de ciberseguridad
que se publicaron en la revista
británica vi jay que vemos pues primero
que el 88 por ciento incluyen un código
o unas licencias que les permiten
compartir a terceros la información que
el usuario le da a esta aplicación eso
es muchísimo es casi nueve de cada diez
la inmensa mayoría estas aplicaciones
por cierto eran aplicaciones gratuitas
que se encontraban en google en google
play que es uno de los mercados de
aplicaciones más usados también el 28 1%
no tenían una política específica de
privacidad y el 23 por ciento
comunicaban a sus datos de forma
insegura es decir que en el momento de
pasar esta información que ellos
recolectan a una tercera parte en ese
proceso la información no estaba
encriptada y eso significa que también
tenían acceso o era visible estos datos
para pues el servidor el software el
programa que hacía este paso de datos
eso es mucha información circulando en
el mundo digital y adónde puede llegar
esta información bueno las opciones son
múltiples y sobre todo en las
aplicaciones que son gratuitas por eso
le preguntamos a uno de los autores del
estudio que lo entrevistamos en francés
24 el profesor muhammad y quedan
escuchemos lo
de las aplicaciones que analizamos son
gratis no tienen costo de bell x v10
application de kite runner país los
desarrolladores que las hacen intentan
monetizar su aplicación recogiendo los
datos para publicidad en el tranquilo
show
venden los datos en mercados digitales a
todo tipo de terceros como anunciantes o
rastreadores para monetizar las
básicamente nuestros datos pueden estar
vendiéndose cómo funciona todo ese flujo
de información pues el usuario pone
datos en la aplicación puede ser datos
desde nutrición ejercicio ciclo
menstrual pero también productos que
compran en la forma y hay muchísimas
opciones de datos alrededor de nuestra
salud que pueden ser significativos
estas estas aplicaciones lo pueden pasar
a terceros qué tipo de terceros pues
buscadores anunciantes y gente que hace
este proceso que se llama data harvest
que es recolección de datos buscará
patrones también en esos datos esto
dónde empieza el problema también no
puede pasarse al proceso que se llama
data mining data mining que sería
traduciéndolo como minería de datos
básicamente es procesar toda esta
información para darle un sentido útil
un sentido por ejemplo estadístico y que
incluso puede re identificar es decir
datos que habían perdido pues su
asociación con la persona quien
pertenecían estos datos pueden volver a
conectarse con una asombrosa al menos
asombrosa para las personas que no
sabemos tanto de tecnología asombrosa
facilidad no y qué pasa puede hay
muchísimas personas que quieren estos
datos y más en temas de salud de una
información
particularmente sensible por ejemplo
pues gente que quiere hacer
investigación sólo con eso pero también
compañías de seguro no seguros de vida
por ejemplo que quieren saber pues qué
condiciones de salud puedes tener la
preocupación también de que incluso
emplea puedan saber si una persona está
embarazada o no si una persona tiene
alguna enfermedad o no o no o
diagnósticos verdaderamente sensibles y
por supuesto también compañías de
anunciantes que quieren dirigir sus
productos a las personas que creen que
pueden estar interesadas pero
básicamente la conclusión es que esta
información queda a merced de quien
quiera usarla y de que sobre todo de
quién fuera pueda comprarla no este
gráfico además web bueno es totalmente
simplificado hay muchísima más huella
digital también de aplicaciones de
centros de salud que usan estas
tecnologías digitales para compartir
diagnósticos o información y pues quien
sepa identificar todos estos datos quien
sepa procesarlos y quien sepa darles un
significado tiene realmente muchísima
más información sobre nuestra salud a
veces de la que el propio usuario tiene
y también pues los riesgos que todo esto
conlleva a marc muchísimas gracias como
siempre por toda la información de salud
pasamos entonces a ver nuestro segundo
invitado